افادت وكالته رويترز بان اليابان يحتجت
رسميا ان لدى الصين بسبب التعليق بجين
اصدارات تاشيرات الدخول قصيره الامر
لمواطنيها وكنت الصين قد توقفت عن اصدار
التاشيرات قصيره المدى لمواطني كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان ردا على القيود التي
فرضتها الدوله على المسافرين الصينيين على
خلفيه انتشار فايروس كورونا وتسمح اليابان
للزوار القادمين من الصين بالدخول في حاله
كانت نتيجه فحص كودرد الخاصه بهم سلبيا
السفير والصينيه ولادا روسيا
ضد الطرفه عن المعركه التي تاخدها الصين
في مواجهه وباء كرونه واضافها في تصريح
انه ولدته وكاله توباس الروسيه للانباء ان
الولايات المتحده ودولا غربيه اخرى تتهم
بالجين بفقدان السيطره على انتشار فيروس
كورونا بهدف في رد الطرف عن الانجاز الذي
حققته الصين وذلك من اجل تشويه صورتها على
حد تعبيره